we're calling it heading into Autumn
you're about to see a whole lot more of
the bell bottom cut we keep seeing it
all over social and it basically Blends
an a-line cut which creates more volume
around the cheekbones before flicking
out into extended ends with a pair of
squishy curved curtain bangs the flicked
bottom pays homage to the iconic bell
bottom jeans that were a signature of
the 70s and also the curtain Fringe is
very 70s Vibes too but the cut also has
loads of super wearable internal layers
which is very 90s and helps to give it
that lift boost and airiness it can work
on curls waves straight hair the trick
is to create that sort of waterfall
layered shape that starts more tapered
and ends wider and as much as the cut is
important styling is key so curl creams
to create that definition Barrel brushes
to blow dry in some 90s volume and
texturizers to lock in some Airy
movements so there you have it it's
heavy it's swooshy it's a little bit
fringy it has Autumn hair Vibes written
all over it